okay hi everyone welcome to another
design review about arrays
and uh i guess we are
we this is our fifth meeting in this
series
and
we are looking we're going to start off
today
reviewing
back-end storage technology for arrays
is that correct
yes
okay where should we start
should we survey the ones that we're
going to remove from our discussion just
to make sure we're all on the same page
the existing models with good story and
wolfram language
yeah we thought uh that probably these
things they already represented quite
well
okay all right
okay well i mean the encore versions are
right the in-core version of these is
yeah sure yes
sure
um
i mean like a sparse array one can
imagine being having some out of core
manifestation but we're not discussing
that right now
yeah
yeah okay all right
okay you guys are in charge what's next
do you want to share your screen or no
no i mean we can look at this document
on your screen if you want but basically
the idea is that first you have storage
technology divided by basically the
shape the data takes so document based
are things like [ __ ]
tabular is everything from
relational databases to
data frames
uh all sorts of stuff like that
triple stores are rdf so sparkle and key
values are things like reddis
and company what about graph stores for
example graph stores are triple stores
uh yeah actually uh before we go
uh
one important thing here is that when we
looked at that list that we inherited
from the previous meeting
the big problem with that list was that
it wasn't properly classified according
to certain uh you know properties and so
we've picked uh several which are
storage technology
storage form if you scroll slightly down
then what we call computational model
which is uh distinct from storage
technology which is more about the apis
and query languages and the degree of
integration with wolfram language so all
back ends which are listed here
we tried to categorize according to this
for
proper okay so let me understand what
when you say storage technology
in some sense you mean how do you
reference an element
in the store
to give an example the distinction
between storage technology computational
model
is that
for example you can use sparkle to query
something that is not necessarily a
graph but it i mean there is a
translation layer from sparkler to sql
and so you can query with spark or
traditional scale database and that is
also true of most all up implementations
so in a sense the computational model is
like the api you use for querying while
the storage technology is how they're
stored disk or whatever server or memory
okay what shape that takes
okay
well i understand those storage forms
although although i don't quite
understand
i mean server and cloud
is do you mean a database because there
can be files in the cloud
what do you mean by that
it means that it's abstracted like
it means that of course of course in the
end database when you drill down it's
more or less going to be implemented
through files
but the the you're not accessing it as a
file you're not opening you're not
importing
you're accessing it differently or you
don't you don't you don't have an actual
file handle in the os sense you have
some abstracted api i presume is what
you're getting at so your
streaming api as opposed to the
traditional
file handle api or something like that
but what about i'm sorry what about a
more of a
you know a restful api as opposed to you
said streaming api
that's different
yeah but this is more about the
computational model and the story no no
no no we're talking about storage form
right now
um i think what we had in mind was to
classify according to how
sort of close it is to the process where
the the current process like a memory is
the closest files is still local
not on with the network but still uh on
the os
and everything else is network
yeah but i mean in a sense like when you
were talking
like databases
sometimes can sidestep files themselves
like they have a special relationship
with the
with the file system right so they they
don't act as files for the us
yeah they usually do block level storage
they don't do files
but but the api the computational model
usually
you decide what are the ways to access
it um
and there are certain primitives that
you make very fast and then you
decompose everything in terms of those
um
so
that's sql has a very little language
which syntactically is made a little bit
i
bigger
in
the
you're saying data frame is part of
table based i mean it's not the same as
what do you mean by table do you mean
two-dimensional you mean something
different
yeah pretty much two-dimensional okay
then why is data frame part of that
because data frames most most data
frames are two-dimensional okay but but
we already discussed how we want to make
something i'm not saying that our data
frame is going to be i'm talking about
all right on this data frame and
arrow and whatnot so when people talk
about these all right okay okay what are
we trying to achieve with this list
uh well there are a number of backends
that we wanted to classify according to
what kind of
uh where they are in this space and if
you look at the dataset below uh it
contains those big ends so we tried to
find some orthogonal properties to use
this classification that's what we came
up with oh yeah all right but i mean
look the bottom line here is we're going
to be implementing certain things
so we can classify as much as we want
but in the end we're going to be
implementing certain things so hopefully
this is contributing to that
well yes but we did exactly as you
requested us for that list that's what
we've done
okay all right okay okay all right well
let's i what was that what was the thing
i'm sorry you have to remind me
this is these are
technologies
yeah
i see these are either database uh
server based or
otherwise database engines which are
widely used
or
some of them are distributed or used for
big data
some of them are um they i mean
this is
reasonably representative list of
technologies that
uses out of core data
and queries them
okay
okay so
and some of these are things we use
right now we have links to right now
some we do not
yes and you're going to make some
proposal
last column tell us a step
yeah you can look at uh
basically integration level
uh there are some links that we yeah
okay okay i get it i get it what's the
difference between research and
prototype
well i made up this list but basically
research means that some work has been
done
but uh nothing of uh i was at least
aware of was
in the shape where we could say that
something is actually
uh working to the extent that we can say
okay this is kind of a prototype while
for radius for instance we know that it
was used inside internally for
cloud exploration so i inserted
prototype here as a sign that it was
actually used so
probably we have something working
okay
is there a proposal here for what we
should do
well i i think there might be multiple
proposals uh here like
for for sure one thing that comes out of
this is that the tabular
uh space is very rich
and there are
many approaches that tend to bridge
several versions of this together
while
as far as we could tell much of the
you know trying to uh have hierarchical
hierarchical data or document based and
tabular lived together have mostly
failed
okay
what what is olap for those of us who
are not expert in databases
so all app is more of a
multi-dimensional way of looking at uh
the at
databases it stands for
online processing what's that
online analytical processing
really i don't know that's good before
okay
uh this is basically a case where you
have lots of uh really lots and lots of
data
that form some kind of multi-dimensional
grid of sorts
uh
and which you want to analyze by taking
certain sections and computing certain
aggregations on those sections
yeah people talk about all up cubes
okay okay okay okay so so this is
related to a thing we long studied which
is the question of
if you have a you know huge amount of
weather data let's say and you want to
be able to
compute certain short queries quickly
like the average temperature in a month
as opposed to the average temperature
from the 21st of the month at 2pm blah
blah blah blah to whatever
there is you know this is this data
summarization date data
uh hierarchical
you know data summarization type thing
is that correct
it doesn't have to be hierarchical but
it has to it can be multi-dimensional
no but i i understand but the purpose of
it is to be able to do things for us
would be to be able to do things like
given a large amount of data be able to
cache the results for you know the mean
of the slice of the data am i making
sense
one of the possible things yes
um
i i'm confused okay
what is it useful for to us
this kind of approach
the thing i just described or something
different
i don't i don't just want the general
marketing pitch for olap i've heard that
a million times
well i i don't think it is the most
useful thing here i mean it's it's kind
of falling out of fashion in favor of a
more data framing approach
um i think it's solving a different
problem it's solving that solving a
different problem
right the data frame problem is solving
the problem as we discussed previously
of you have internally you have data
stored in some efficient format and
we're talking about a few different
formats for that but it is some
dense
structured format on the outside you
want to access the data through certain
you know part specifications and you
want to wrap the data
through cert with
you know units or missing stuff or
whatever else that's i'm
array i'm talking about what kind of
apis people who do
i understand but i'm trying to clarify
what it is that's useful about these
things okay and and the thing that i
think
the thing we've described there
is element at a time
getting the element you want getting it
in the right form am i making sense
that's what this data frame thing is
specifically you know is is what that
that's what that would achieve for us am
i right
i would disagree on one element at a
time
in that
data frame makes it very natural to work
with say a column at a time whatever
column means here
but but okay okay okay so so then the
thing that we need to think about is
if it is a column at a time
there is a question are you just getting
the raw data or are you getting some
aggregation of that column you
understand what i'm saying
uh yeah it depends but no no it doesn't
depend it's the whole point is we're
trying to look now we're trying to get
performing an aggregation or not but the
point is that the cool thing about the
data frame for us is like it's listable
by default basically it's listable first
and that's where it ties in with the
other discussion on arrays that threaded
and so on
well
okay
i think i need to go back to my previous
notes
okay so what did this come from
specifically
what what part of this were you trying
to add to
there was the list of backends that use
and technologies here
you see general technologies in back
ends where you you started to build this
list
and then so where's hdf on your list
oh actually hdf is missing
great um
yeah that's my fault because i rest csv
on your list
um
hdf is a format as well
but hdf contains a rich a rather rich
api which makes it a little bit more
than just a format
csv is mostly just uh
put it another way people people don't
usually work with usb
on the csv file they they import it in
some way and then they can serialize
back to csv but you don't
actively work on the csv okay so so the
thing that we did not describe here
okay
is
uh
we didn't describe it the olap case that
we did not describe
is something where there is the result
of some partial operation already stored
in the data container
am i making sense
okay look look
the end result of these meetings cannot
be an infinite series of meetings the
point of these meetings is to come up
with a small number of things that we
are then going to implement
of which data container scaffolded array
whatever it's called is definitely one
of them
do we agree
absolutely
okay so let's just write down what we
know we're gonna do
okay i was just trying to parse what you
just said about storing the result
what that means actually okay well so so
the one thing we have here we know we're
gonna have data container
whatever it's called right data
container
and uh
now
data container the api
what does the api look like the api
has
these
basically
i guess it's like the crud interface
well no that's read write the data
container is is at first a read-only
initially read-only is that correct
see the thing is okay listen guys the
thing we have to do here we're not just
going to do an infinite series of
meetings we are going to do a design and
implement the design and i'm i'm
concerned that what you've got here is
not moving us towards that it's just a
circling
if i'm making sense
uh yeah i mean okay so tell me what tell
me what we learned from what you've got
here that helps us move towards a design
rather than just circling around which
i'm not that interested i i think that
one of the most interesting examples of
of these that we found while looking at
this is what they've been trying to do
in in
which is especially interesting because
it comes from a similar uh functional
programming language is the uh if you
click on
uh
in
tables.the jl integrations in julie
under julia integration is is a link
the first bullet point first bullet
point integrations is a link
okay
so we can't figure it out for ourselves
so we're just going to look at what
somebody else has done no what what what
come on
i'm just saying that what is impressive
here is that by restricting restricting
two tables so 2d
things they are able to do the all those
integrations which include csv
etc
they're all different it's like all of
these are open source projects so some
are high quality some are just
experimental of course but they share
the same
api which is just great
brilliant yeah of course
it's crap come on guys
come on let's have you gone through this
and figured out if there's anything
actually reasonable here or are we just
going to see a bunch of spelling lists
yeah the interface what they decided is
the common api is reasonable then is the
documentation for the yeah
where is the common api
line below interface is another link
so basically if you
if you implement five of these you can
subscribe
okay
so okay so these are kind of obvious
things right what is materializer
let's see i mean materializer is the
most interesting thing because it's the
thing that allows you to transform from
one another and so you basically take a
csv file and allows you to import it and
maybe move it directly into sqlite
that's what it does
okay it's a sync function
oh yeah okay great
all right well
maybe you guys can study that in more
detail i think that's not the most
interesting thing for us
um can we actually get to okay what else
do we learn from this or should we just
go back to what we were doing before
what else do we learn from what you've
done here i don't understand what we
learned we had specific objectives last
time we're trying to move towards those
objectives we're not circling around
making it just
so what i was trying to say is that for
me the thing that is clear about this is
that there is definitely a lot of
common ground in everything that is
rectangularish 2d
and those can share an api there's a
bunch of things that a bunch of projects
that allow you to say
write
some kind of generic sql to query things
that are not relational databases
because in the end they're all
transformations in this space of 2d
structures so i think that that would be
the first place where i put
our weight like trying to understand the
2d case very well
and let me add that as far as 2d
constructs our tabular data import
export support csv tsvxl we have some
common api as far as common elements and
so forth in there already which is
pretty solid
it doesn't go beyond formats obviously
but as far as we are talking about
formats that's that's there that's solid
okay so
so i don't understand
what
look
we already have a concept it's called
dataset
it's working quite well
you're proposing uh what i thought we
were trying to do before we went off
track here is we're trying to make
something which is like dataset it's a
column-oriented thing it's an efficient
storage mechanism for
lists of associations and so on that's a
thing we need to achieve i'm not really
that interested in going off on a giant
exploration of everybody else's
randomness well hold on last time we
talked about we talked about you know
having
having
more specific you know
more specific back ends that were more
restrictive and then we were going to
package those up in some way that was
going to be more general fine right and
so one of the questions was what more
specific back ends you know are worth
having
and how would those fit in with some
more general thing that would
incorporate several of these together
stephen do you mean
did you mean to say that data set is
column oriented because i disagree no no
it's not column oriented that's the
whole point what i'm saying is the thing
we know we need to do which we already
talked about
is whether it's through this data
container thing we need something which
will take lists of associations
associations of associations you know
hierarchical collections of listeners no
no that's that's what we learned more or
less is that if you want to take lists
of associations association association
random hierarchical stuff and levels
deep you lost
that the really cool stuff stays within
the 2d realm i don't believe you i don't
i i think i think that's a very good i
don't believe you i know it's a common
case it's the case that's been being
done since the 1960s it's the case
that's been being done probably since
the original hollerith card sorter
is definitely to improve this very
commonly right so what we need to design
that what is
isn't data set our arbitrary
hierarchical
viewer right i mean yes but it isn't
efficient because it doesn't deal with
it doesn't have the thing that we need
that we already discussed about six
times or actually probably at least four
times because the fifth meeting in the
series the thing that we know we need is
an efficient storage mechanism for
nested collections of lists and
associations where we're not restoring
the keys of the association for every
element and where the thing is
basically not ragged we don't worry
about the ragged case we know we already
talked about this we already talked
about if it's small fraction ragged
small fraction missing we have various
kinds of ways to handle that that's the
thing we need to handle now other people
have worked on the two-dimensional case
at length
we should certainly learn from what
they've done
we should not restrict
maybe we have a special efficiency hack
for the two-dimensional case but the
path that we were on which is the one we
should be following is one where we make
efficient because i don't think it's
going to be more difficult to do that
than these other things we make much
more efficient the arbitrary depth
ragged list association
hierarchical thing no i'm sorry
non-ragged uh
version of this does that make sense
yeah i think it's easy stephen it's it's
it's actually mappable to the 2d case
may very well be yeah it is in some way
other than the way fortran does it
no i mean we've been we it's it's map of
the 2d case like our packed eraser i
mean we represent we represent the
dimensions in some way that includes
keys when they should should have
included
and then if we
require some
required dimensions to work which it
already does for
for array but we represent keys
keys instead of numbers
then you can do this
okay so so just so i understand
the the number one thing that we want to
do is we want to have something where
there's essentially some kind of
transducer some translator address
translation unit that goes from the this
is what we discussed last time and the
time before which goes from the part
number you request which might be a list
part or an association key some sequence
of those things to actually extract the
element you need
then there's the question of how much
can you do
all together with a particular column
row
other slice
am i making sense
yep
okay so can i have a prototype of that
okay
but um
so think what what
at this point
one thing which we discussed already in
the first meeting is that both jose and
rob has arrived at is that you can have
different types in the last dimension
only
but that mirrors this fact that it's
basically a 2d case where the last
dimension are the columns
okay so so what you're saying is
i mean the way that you're describing
that is
every
the list of indices
you're describing that as
it doesn't matter that the prefix
indices
are out an outer product
right correct correct yeah
that's exactly it
okay
yeah and and clearly we can have a
container that can happily mix keys and
numbers yes that's what i'm saying the
the the association and
list okay so let's okay so i think we're
we're brilliant that this is we're
agreeing on this part of it
okay
now the question that
that i wanted to understand so okay
so some of the issues there are what to
do with missings what to do with small
amounts of raggedness
and what i'm assuming right hold on just
to get give a few answers along the way
we have to represent missing
without at least minimally we need to
represent it it is missing in an
efficient way
um
and some of these back ends do that i
think several of them do it actually
almost all
okay yeah
and then
there's another layer of what to do
you know i think that's needed for
workflows but but
you know the core storage technology is
probably not going to do that
right do you mean so the algebra of
missing that two plus missing is also
missing or something like that
well not necessarily i mean i think i
don't notice storage technology
implements in algebra particularly no no
no sure but but we kind of i mean this
is something that sort of has come up
many times before right which is that
you know if you have if you have a big
list with some missings in it you try
and do any kind of you know if you do
mean of a list that contains a missing
you get back this sort of algebraic gunk
right
oh i see what you're saying no i mean we
need to clearly work on the workflows
and so there are at least two ways of
doing it there could be a sort of an
algebra that it poisons everything
but there's also the thing of filling in
missing with different methods and there
are a bunch of different methods yeah
yeah we've got that i mean we've got
synthesized
yeah but just need to work at sort of
scale and and right yeah i mean a lot of
these a lot of these uh like to give the
simplest example is sql which also has
the right computational model for the
sticky missings and you can
i mean you can set defaults
from where where you want to like fill
in the missings as well so
a lot of these servers will do it for
you
whatever i mean you know that
okay so this is a separate thing the
algebra of missing and these different
operations that you might do and i mean
i think one could imagine a situation in
which there's something called you know
missing function or something
um which says what to do with the
missing which has these various actions
to take when you run into a missing when
you're doing certain kinds of operations
i think there might already be a missing
function in time series
or something like that
yes yeah
which which deals with almost exactly
this this issue of what do you fill it
in what are you filling missings with i
think it's called missing handler maybe
not missing function
is it missing function or missing
behavior as well for query
missing data method maybe
okay
so
right well actually by the way maybe
what one other question is kind of
related is is how do these i mean how do
most of these systems represent missings
you know in in these sort of packed
forms i mean do they just use some you
know ieee nan kind of thing or
do they have something more
sophisticated
uh it depends but in most cases the null
is separate from nan
okay but it's it's just some special you
know if you have a pac-ray floats let's
say it's just some special you know
float or something that's that
represents missing
i'm wondering basically like can you
have because you know for us with
missing you know our missings can have
parameters and stuff like that which
kind of makes it a little more
complicated because it's not just
missing it's missing and this is the
reason and this is the expert and so on
yeah i'm wondering
like i think most most of these
backhands implement missing that
separate from not a number
but you can't attach metadata to why
it's missing
it's just you cannot
yeah okay so so we might say that the
floating point number you know
you know 10 to the minus 300 for example
is is represents a missing and then when
we hit that number we look up and see if
that's in the missing table exactly
right exactly
so we could have a number of different
missings we should have different tokens
different types of missing and if it's
not in the missing table then we treat
it as that number
okay and is it okay right and so then
there isn't a risk of uh
of of numbers mysteriously don't yes
that removes numbers going missing
guys that that won't work with with
existing out of course solutions like
that you you're you're gonna have one
type of missing only then
because otherwise you don't get the
efficiency what are you talking about
what are you talking about what we're
interested in is is
that's only relevant if you're doing
operations out of core right
can i uh interject that you know we keep
talking about efficiency but we're not
very clear about what kind of efficiency
so stephen and i think you're really
focused on space efficiency because you
don't want the duplicate keys and
whatnot
and that's going to come at a cost of
you know
various slice efficiencies or you know
you know
algorithmic time efficiency well i i
don't know i mean i think that there's
sometimes i think for example the other
thing that rob is talking about
almost certainly i mean
with a little bit of work but it could
almost certainly come with lots of time
efficiency stuff because fundamentally
it's just about for certain
for certain slices
right okay the question is this the
question is this guys
that the
you know in terms of time efficiency the
problem is what if your slice isn't a
contiguous slice
what if you want a non-contiguous slice
right yes
contiguous well i mean in in rob's
method anything which has a given prefix
index sequence
the thing you get out with a given
prefix index sequence is going to be
a thing that somehow you can just pick
it up and do something with it if on the
other hand what you want
is you know in tensor notation if what
you wanted was something like you know
one three four i
five
three
i or something you wanted to do a a you
know einstein summation convention
across those two indices
that would be difficult to do in rob's
scheme
well i think i think if we if we keep
this idea of rectangularish to be
allowing raggedness only in the very
last dimension
it wouldn't be as efficient but it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be terrible
terrible
is that because
fortran like
there is a fixed stride that you go
through right exactly it's it it gives
us a fixed stride to work with that's
that's that's
i mean i i don't know why why are we
talking about this like
when you say because we're trying to
actually implement something paulo yeah
but what we're talking about when you're
taking the slice of a big data set you
don't care about strides and whatnot
you're doing a you're filtering over
some property and if you redefine the
missing to be some random phone we're
not talking about
on the
on the on the server
i think this is that lowers everything
and i think the stride thing is like in
the implementation you know you need to
have stuff like that like i think that
the stride issue is a level lower lower
level than what you're talking about i
think yeah that's right it's an
implementation level
right and the problem with strides is
you don't keep things in the cache if
the stride is too big
among other things
but the point i mean the thing the thing
that is potentially nice is that this
the storage would be
you know column oriented across the last
dimension so if you wanted to do stuff
across columns you'd have relatively
efficient efficient access
[Music]
okay
okay but so so what you're building rob
as i understand it is this data
container mechanism
where
there is efficient access to elements
where it is possible to
get an efficient slice
out
i mean okay the things you can do
presumably are
extract an element
or a slice
right of some kind where we define
um when you extract an element okay
process
uh quantity etc wrapping
well extraction element mapping from
uh
mapping keys
appropriately right right
okay process quantity etc
uh wrappers
in other words return quantity etc
wrappers as appropriate
eg by the way by the way though i mean
that that one is also one that that
would be great for packed raise
i can't call it that one is just as
useful i mean it's it's just as useful
to have quantities and packed arrays as
it is to have quantities in this this
thing
well i think pacquiao should be kept tax
for raised we can put pact raise into
this thing as the
as the underlying storage
and then you have it for packed race
okay so
could you have i i guess then you could
have as opposed to having a
you know if i had a big number of reels
and there's a couple of missings in it
or a couple of you know or if there are
quantities associated with it then your
point is that i the solution is not to
have a packed array with quantities
associated it the solution is just to
have one of these
you know
okay fine yeah right but then when it
returns quantity wrappers or geoposition
etc wrappers it will do so in some cases
returning to top level something like a
quantity array
rather than a list of quantity objects
if i request a slice
if you ask a column probably yes if you
ask a row then no
well but also i mean i thought that part
of the thing we were talking about was
sort of having it so that it you know
i don't know i mean i i don't know how
transparent this thing is right i mean
is this something where
is this a kind of a secret thing like
packed array or is this something where
it's going to be very visible
i think maybe it might be visible but i
think it should go underwater eventually
well i'm using steven's paradigm from
last time before we said we're going to
want to start with it be invisible and
hopefully make it invisible at some
point okay fine but i'm just thinking
about i mean so so if it because because
if it were if it were invisible or if
we're thinking about the invisible the
theoretical invisible phase
then
you know then it might just look like a
list of quantities and not like a
quantity array exactly yes right i agree
which is the way it should look in the
end
um
i mean we might want it to print
differently and things like that
you know
what should
the print form i mean i don't actually
know whether we thought about this
recently what should the print form
um of a quantity array be
in other words it could be
that you'd actually want it to say two
three four
meters not two meters three meters four
meters
and we're making sense which again would
improve some efficiency
okay
yeah one other question is how is it oh
sorry christopher okay go ahead go ahead
uh do we plan this this uh solution this
structure to to also handle some
operations
like if you can you can can you do log
on on a column
well that's the question okay so let's
let's let's let's come to that in a
minute and and i i i'm asking this now
uh simply because uh uh
together with missing the stuff like uh
indeterminate and stuff like because
right now
you know we have stuff like unpacking
and this is a problem for like handling
you know big databases you don't want to
like [ __ ] call them reals let's
let's let's do various let's talk about
various things actually there's a
question on a live stream from nick
about ml dataset which is apparently i
don't even know how this works
julio that's probably your area the the
innards of the machine learning system
what is the username
um
that's it just the data set in the end
but
it's what is this ml
what is that yeah it's a different head
it's backed by data set it's just used
to i can i can give you a demo if you
want next time uh
but what's the point of it and how does
it relate to what we're talking about
here
the point is to whenever you throw you
throw rows at stuff at functions like
classify for example like rows because
you give an array with
a temperature a number a boolean
and then we store it in a
column-oriented way internally
and given that data set is not golum
oriented
there's a little api around it to i
think so one fight extraction sampling
stuff like that right so once data
container exists you would expect to or
whatever it's going to be called you
would expect to use it for that purpose
oh yeah yeah i'm just waiting for this
to be real and switch to that
okay fine okay christopher did you have
something and then i want to talk about
operations within data container well
this is kind of related to operations
but i guess the question is um how
i mean how we deal with effectively
packing and unpacking so for example if
you you know i can imagine lots of there
are lots of ways that you would end up
with a list of quantities and the
question is how you would know or maybe
how you could even request
that this be kind of uh packaged up if
you know what i mean
right because it's like import elements
it's like should it end up as a quality
array it should end up as something else
and in the end it's not going to matter
because it's all going to be invisible
hopefully yes but i mean it's like i
mean it's like the issue we talked about
the other day about about or last time
about um you know if you map over a
packed array how does it know whether
the result is packed or not
you could assume it always is and if it
cannot park it it just replace your
garbage with something that parks
maybe most of the time is what you want
if you care about the
integrity of your i guess the point here
though is that this is this is
a little more flexible where there are
lots and lots of different things that
might return something that could be
you know in this in a format that can be
data containerized whatever the term is
right so i don't know i mean maybe it's
maybe it's like packed arrays where
there are certain functions that realize
that their outputs you know they need to
check if their outputs can be packed
um
but then a lot of other functions will
just not and maybe that's the way to do
it
but i think fundamentally i think for
for like easiness so i'm talking about
my use here and what of like probably
many other people
uh i would like this to be
with some mecha opt-in or opt-out
mechanism which you don't have right now
impact arrays yeah because sometimes you
do care about storing whatever you you
you have whatever you have returned and
that's important some other times it's
less important
and you
want to sacrifice it and i guess that's
the thing we were also talking about
which maybe would be nice to protect
race too about having a head right so if
you use the head where it's you know if
you use the visible form then you're
guaranteed that it's using it but you
know of course if you're using the
invisible form then the guarantees are
are kind of out the window but i guess
i'm just asking about in the invisible
case which maybe we shouldn't think too
much about right now because that's sort
of in the future but in the invisible
case you know how it uh how it basically
deals with the same issue that packed
array deals with of figuring out when to
pack and when it can't pack
right
so
okay let's talk about
all right so
some of these operations are just
extraction operations
now the question is what if you want
something aggregated what if you want to
select selector function running within
the data container
which depends on these things that were
over here on the left of how actually is
the inners of the data container stored
okay so so rob what is your approach
right now to the innards of the data
container the things you're building are
they in core innards
yeah everything everything i'm trying to
play with is in core
i mean my my concept and this is the
part i haven't done as a prototype yet
is to have
you know so you have you have
you know
so the last dimension can be ragged but
basically you specify columns based on
that and that could be say
a column of images or a column of
integers
um so we could have types and quantities
um across the last dimension
and so everything will access stuff so
those columns could be
you know uh presumably extended to these
out of core things and maybe there's a
better way to do that but but that's a
that's a that's a possibility with this
well so wait a minute so what you're
suggesting is that the the higher levels
the prefix indices
are in core indices
but then the
final payload
at the at the lowest level is something
that could be out of core is that what
you're saying
yeah i think so
okay so let's review how that relates to
i mean like as i understand it like the
[ __ ] style databases that is exactly
what they would deal with they they have
a bunch of metadata that is
kind of
encore-ish metadata and then they have
some big payload underneath or maybe
those are can somebody comment on that
please
am i right that payload is typically a
file or something
what rob was talking about is that you
might have actually a database in the
in place of the leaves
am i right rob i'm not sure if i got
your proposal it could it could be a
database um yeah i don't think that's
that's certainly a possibility
but my only concern is is this in
in core structure that that we have uh
scalable and and how much like can it
scale up to tens of millions of entries
efficiently
if it stays in court i think it i think
it potentially could you know it depends
i mean i mean you know i guess i guess
one question is how
i mean how many how many
different tabular columns do you
typically expect i don't think i'm
assuming there's not going to be you
know millions and millions of different
absolutely that could be millions of
columns absolutely don't even know
millions of columns columns not rows
that's correct there could be millions
of columns just as there could be
millions of rows
we have no guarantee that people are
going to store their data i mean you
know the columns could be you're
thinking that the columns are you know
height weight and and something or other
and hair color or something but i'm
thinking about columns that are in some
you know graph representation of
something they are the you know the
output from
uh
you know case one two three four five
six seven eight up to a million
see what i'm saying there's absolutely
nothing that says that the number of
columns is small
yeah fine so so the ideas i have might
not work so well for that i mean it's
still
still probably possible but probably
less less effective okay but but so i'm
trying to understand and again this
relates to the things we have on the
left
you know
okay for sql
that is basically a two-dimensional
tabular thing that's essentially the
outer product rows and columns
so
can we comment there i mean i don't
think a typical sql database could
doesn't really care whether the large
number of things is in the rows or in
the columns or in both of them so long
as it's not too small no you can't have
a lot of columns there's a limit i think
on the number of columns it's like 30 in
a lot of databases really
yeah right i mean
these are
the effectiveness of having types across
columns which i think is kind of a key
thing we're talking about
all right so in your model rob
the
the
row index
is the one is the final index
is the one that is after all of the
prefix you know things
you see this is the point the point is
what what's needed for this data
container is what you're basically what
you're basically saying is pick an index
that's going to be a lot of it
you can deal with any of those you just
transpose the thing right
right if you have two indices where
there are lots of them
well that's going to be the square of
the number of elements and it's you know
could be ridiculous
but in general
you're saying we're not handling that at
this time is that correct
we're handling the case where the data
container has one index that gets big
that that gets which
is it's a very very common case that a
lot of people will be happy that's fine
i agree i agree it's a very common case
right and we're giving some additional
flexibility by the fact that our
translator our address translator
doesn't really care which you know can
deal with the transpositions needed to
have that index
appear naturally wherever it feels like
appearing am i am i making sense i think
i think i mean i think a key question is
where do
where do types and and units appear
at the in
well they appear i think at the bottom
yeah
right so if you have a million poems you
have a million different units
no well i mean think the world quantity
array does is i mean i think it has most
of the time you have a single unit no no
but uh
you're probably saying unit stays on the
short
axis not on the long axis yeah i mean
and units is a good k like could be
a million strings columns
some dates some strings some numbers
some
you know what is
we care about
why not
i i i i care about the case we can
already do well which is numbers
no no no the thing we care about is
fairly uniform data right
a list of strings is what he's talking
about i think that's something we
probably do want to we do want to care
about yes we do care about that but i
just want to clarify the whole point is
we've got a sequence of indices here
that
and with those indices
are
okay okay look we got what have we got
we've got the specifier basically
you know
element specifier
for the data container
okay we've got we've the first thing
we've got
is the list of indices
okay
i'm sorry of raw industries no i mean i
mean the list of indices it's either
integers
or keys
yeah but those are raw indices not
column indices
i don't care what kind of industries
they are i think there might be many
questions here
it doesn't it doesn't matter the whole
point is okay there's a list of indices
and okay of which
one
can have large cardinality
does that make sense
do you understand what i'm saying that's
basically the one that's like you know
in in sql you can have lots of rows but
not lots of columns so here this is
deeper there's one one dimension which
you can have lots of stuff
right and that could be it could be the
case
that it's the top dimension that the
whole thing
is a list of records so to speak where
each record contains a
you know name rank and serial number so
to speak if i'm making sense
right or it could be
that
the
you know that the big dimension is the
last index
actually i mean hold on a second i mean
based on based on rob's description of
how this this this works it it doesn't
sound like you're really restricted to
have one
big dimension
right like maybe
the bottom dimension can't be big yeah
well but one can have large cardinality
and that butt one is the bottom it's
like the row one yeah
now wait a minute it's not the road that
the rogue can have
what do you mean the road so to the
point the point is if you can you can
have you can have any you have any
number of of any cardinality for all the
indices except the bottom where you have
height width you know height weight
whatever right
i see okay okay that was a that's a
different way of explaining it but but
then okay okay so
then
somebody has background noise by the way
um
okay
then
for the
short
dimension
there are
also types associated is that right yeah
and and by the way i mean
right types and also quantities
yeah
etc associated now when the missings
come in
do they come only they they come
where do they go
the missings can either go into one
entry of a short of the short dimension
or they can presumably go higher level
that can be a missing is that true
i mean you can have a whole row not not
really because
the indices are columns as well really
if you think about it like uh right the
record and rank and so on you can
consider them indices
there's a lot of stuff we can have there
at the bottom like dates too stephen
like um yeah
you know position year positions and
dates
stuff that has additional administrative
information to tell about itself
yes okay so so okay in
at the bottom level at the short
level whatever we call it
it could be
there could be any template any repeated
templates
well but is it i'm not sure is it if
it's i mean maybe this is an
implementation question but it's not
clear whether it's any repeated template
or whether it's really you know some set
of types that that we have efficient
representations of well but what i think
it is no but but but but like dates into
your positions they store things like
geo ellipsoid a lot of exercises
exactly no sure sure right but you only
need to store it once i'm just kind of
saying an implementation thing i mean
one version would be we have some
general i mean we talked about this
before and it sounds like structured
array maybe does a little bit of this as
well where where you have some super
general thing where you can have any
sort of expression packaging of you know
of of the data but another version would
be you know
that that for data for data objects for
geo positions for quantities we have
some you know probably
probably related to the compiler
something some compiled representation
of that type and and it gets you know
represented in that way if that makes
sense yeah yeah okay okay but but but
but but you see the the reason that this
can scale and be efficient is that
there's some form of uniformity that
gets captured yeah right right right but
yeah i'm just saying that so okay so
basically we'll have there'll be certain
certain
shapes of expressions like data objects
or quantities or whatever which will
have specific kind of efficient
representations of where they'll
internally basically be structs and then
you can pack those and and they'll be
uniform and everything so yeah okay in
particular could they be compiled
expressions
if you mean the i mean yes like if
you're talking about the compiled
expression declaration thing yes and it
sounds like that's basically what they
are
right yes i think i think they
potentially could christopher
okay all right okay so now now that we
we're talking about this okay so we
understand what the structure is now the
question is how are we actually storing
the lowest level thing how are we
storing the backend object that rob has
built he's built the in-core version of
this now the thing we want to talk about
is what are the what about the
out-of-core versions and then we come
back to what kind of aggregation
selection etc functions can be supported
directly within the data container even
if the back end of the data container is
a remote server
right so what are the possible back ends
for this data container object
well okay what do you mean by back ends
though because do you mean backends and
where's the because here's maybe a more
basic question right i mean earlier when
we first had you know meeting one of
this
you know a lot of what we were talking
about was integrating things like you
know some of these existing data frame
library you know apache spark and stuff
like that and and now it sounds like you
know we're much more talking about
making our own thing so maybe i mean one
naive question is you know is there i
mean should we just go off and make our
own thing or should we also in addition
to making our own thing you know try and
integrate some apache spark or whatever
it is for special cases because i don't
know if if you know for example i don't
know if those things are really super
efficient and optimized and they're more
optimized than we'll be able to make and
so you know we should i don't think we
know i don't think we know but we
certainly know that databases but we
have a use case okay so
we are using i think arrow as a as an in
an import project import export project
that allows us to bet a dramatic
dramatic speed up of csv xls and etc
by ingesting it into that data container
and then do things
that's in memory arrow
so right okay but i mean
i mean the reason i bring this up also
is because it's it's like uh i mean
for example a lot of the out of course
stuff we were talking about before we
were doing out of core in the form of
okay we're going to use some
you know some library i don't know what
they're called for out of course stuff
and and you know by integrating with
that we'll have out of course support
but i mean it sort of sounds like i mean
if we have this
you know like when you say back end the
question is is back end need a patchy
arrow or does it mean something that we
make that's running on a server side
doesn't mean either of those two
i mean those are two very different
definitions of the word back end
well i understand but for example
leonard's lazy lists
is is presumably something particular
with this one deification that we've
talked about
i would have thought his lazy list would
be directly usable for this i think it
would be what i don't know and i need to
talk to leonoid whether it'd be more
efficient to have you know one laser
list for each column or
you know one lazy list for the whole
thing
yeah uh i think laser list at this point
is uh
more like an interface which has one
particular implementation which is in
memory
uh
so
it's not all in memory it's it's it's
yeah it's going through memory but it
it's back-end storage can be a file
yes exactly but uh what i'm saying is
that uh it has one particular
kind of its model is somewhat more
general than the implementation that
currently exists
uh and so
it can incorporate as back as file back
storage or even in memory storage some
chunks which are for instance rob's
constructs or something else so
and on top of that it will provide them
the interface that allows to use
familiar functions like map or whatnot
okay hold on hold on let i want to come
back again to this question of
rob has a mechanism where he is storing
in memory in an efficient way without
replicating you know association keys
all that kind of thing
our data container type stuff okay let's
now consider the case it's a giant data
container that has you know a billion
rows
each
50 columns wide or something
and
we're storing all of this but the
operations we want to do
are only going to sample some small
piece of this so we want
to store those things in files we never
want them to be moved into memory
and then how do we do that right so what
is that back-end storage is it a
database is it a file is it something
different
what are the possible back-end storage
things
that
we should consider
yeah there are various techniques to do
this okay what are they
so uh the first one is that in general
if you're using a database uh and there
is an important dimension which you
usually sample i i don't care about that
i understand that point okay i'm asking
much more basically i'm asking much more
basically
if we're doing this right
what technologies are we supporting as
the thing that can be you know rob is
going to have this data container thing
where as far as the top level function
is concerned it's just a giant
you know data set like collection of
lists and associations
the question is what is there under the
hood
yeah am i making sense
i mean it sounds like it sounds like
they're probably many possible you know
out of core back ends certainly it
sounds like you could use something like
an sql database because i mean basically
you just need
you know the only thing that you need to
to
right i mean you just need to have the
index and then you have the the columns
and then and then that's basically the
same as how it's going to be represented
internally anyway so
yeah i mean it sounds like they're
probably many different well but what
are they but let's talk about which ones
we already support
okay one thing we already support is sql
databases
we should be able to use an sql database
as the back end so for example for
example
a big question is
where did the data come from
okay you're dealing with a huge amount
of data
where did the data come from
right you didn't make it all you didn't
make that petabyte of data
right so where did it come from it might
be already in an sql database
right it might be already in files
i mean i'm not sure you didn't make it i
mean like for example i mean i've had
projects where i'm doing things like you
know
like i had a project where i went
through you know i parsed all of all of
wikipedia and all the history of
wikipedia right and that's like okay you
get a bunch of zipped xml files and you
iterate over them and you have to be
careful you know you're not
you don't have it all in memory at once
but in the end it's you know like a
terabyte or something
and so it's it's you know i i don't know
i mean i rarely at least for me have i
sort of had cases where i'm dealing with
some massive data set and i got it as an
sql database it's usually not that nice
you made it by processing something else
right i mean and that's by the way a
little bit related maybe to to leonard's
stuff or i mean i i don't know exactly
what work we don't really have a
workflow right now other than maybe lean
its stuff for for doing this because
right now the only way you can really do
that is you know you call read or
something like that or read list
and and you know because you can't
import the whole thing at once but
right yeah okay
so
okay
but whether you made it
and put it what do you put it in after
you've made it
do you put it in an in mx files what do
you put it in oh
you mean for laser list specifically no
i was asking christopher what what what
would be a reasonable thing um
probably in a in a well
in i mean in my case i i mean i didn't
write this in mathematica i wrote it
rust because i couldn't write it
mathematica so i put them in a basically
a a bunch of mx files effectively the
equivalent of a bunch of them x files
okay
go ahead one thing i want to mention
here is one big stumbling block for
streaming
for laser list was that
the mx or wx performance they are not
very well suited because
if you need only a part of what is in
that data you have to load the entire
chunk of memory even if it's a single
chunk
so you don't over overflow the memory
but if you need to for instance doing
out of core sort or other things which
involve many chunks then you do a lot of
work that you don't have to do because
you you simply can't uh only import
parts of the data i guess i understand
yeah and that's that's where this format
that would allow you to only import
parts either based on parker or
uh something else uh similar to that
will be very very useful okay hold on
hold on that's a new different idea
right so so you know there's
storing general expressions
out of core
right
ultimately yes
right so what we have to do that is
we have wxf
have
uh mx files
those are two known methods what else do
we have
how does cloud expression store things
i'm sorry
it's a postgres database
i thought it was a
okay in the end it's a postgres database
but
but
that's an example
i mean an sq lite analog of that would
be an example of a file type thing where
you could get
sub-pieces of it
yes yes that's one of the possibilities
right okay so
the question is
question mark an efficient storage
scheme
with
part access
right because right exactly
right
okay you need file based uh
storage scheme yeah
yeah
right so in other words where you can do
the analog of seek to that part
and extract it exactly okay has anybody
talked to dorian about whether there's
any possibility of putting that into wxf
yeah we talked about it with him
a little bit but uh i think the outcome
of that conversation was that wxf
is not has not been designed with this
sort of efficiency in mind it's kind of
possible but it's not has been designed
specifically okay fine so
in in the world you know what has been
designed
for marquette
apache
okay how does it work
uh
well it has certain specification
of how you store different types and
data on the byte level that's probably
not the only format oh yeah but so
fundamentally what it's probably doing
is it's defining a record size
and then saying to get to part number
blah blah blah you simply go and compute
what byte offset you're going to go to
is that correct
i think so
okay but does not sound very profound i
i wouldn't be surprised if there are
slightly clever things i mean i know for
example with them
i think with um
for example the 7-zip like lcma um
format for for you know compression i
think i think i read somewhere they have
a mechanism where you can sort of seek
to the middle
and they have kind of uh stuff for this
so i wouldn't be surprised if there are
you know all right so let's let's go
find this out and let's go see what it
would take to have something where the
fundamental encoding
is where it's something like a framed
wxf by which i mean
something where
you know when the wxf is storing lots of
identical elements it is it is rigidly
framed in such a way that you can i mean
i don't know whether wxf can have filler
bytes in it if it can then this is
probably rather straightforward
am i making sense
i mean it seems like it almost i mean
the front end has a different idea
which is that it basically computes
little map
the cache
it says where things are
right well and i mean basically this
could be so it needs
we need
you know again an address translation
an address translation function
which could be
a pure
you know
uh basically record size times
you know times index
or it could be more sophisticated
right i mean there could be something
like i mean kind of like what i think
roger was saying you could have
something where i mean like with
notebooks where maybe there's an index
and you can get yourself within a
thousand entries of your target and then
you search from there but i mean again
this seems like this sort of thing where
there there must be maybe this apache
thing that lina was talking about there
must be you know computer theoretical
computer science uh things for this but
one thing i want to mention here is that
uh one complication is that you want to
maintain
uh you know a kind of packed
form
and at the same time it's making things
more complex because if you want to save
on memory and on
you know speed of querying big chunks of
these things at the same time you want
some form of packing on the other hand
if their records are reasonably complex
you have to reconcile this packing with
the complexity of those records well
okay fine but i mean the the obvious
thing would be to store compiled
expressions at the bottom level
either wxf or compile expressions at the
bottom level
well i mean that's basically we don't i
mean okay we right now we don't have a
serialization mechanism for basically
compiled structs but it's probably not
i i don't know how hard that is why do
you say compiled expressions because
that doesn't seem very uniform in size
well no i compile i mean this is just
if you have a type in the compiler i
mean ultimately it'll be like a struct
or something so it will be you know
it'll always be the same size right well
so you don't need general expressions
because yeah
but i mean i would imagine that the main
thing is a is a
framed wxf where okay but but but all of
these things
are kind of
let's talk about aggregation functions
and selection functions
okay i want to find i want to pull out
of my data container those elements
where the third string
has an as a queue in it or something
what do i do and how much of that can be
done can be compiled into something that
is for example i mean we've we've got a
lot of trouble recently to compile a
bunch of stuff into sql right
so for example if we were representing
the long index so to speak or the
non-short indices
if this was represented as rows in an
sql
system
then
we could imagine
i mean these operations within a data
set are looking at the
at the payload data and doing things
based on it
as opposed to what we've been discussing
so far which is just looking at the
indices am i making sense
yeah so so now the question is when we
look at the payload data how do we do it
and how does that work in these
different implementations
for example go ahead
yeah that depends on what the payload
data looks like because if it is
things like numbers or strings or
dates what not
they can be stored natively and then you
have things like i mean now this is i
know so let's assume let's assume that
okay we've been talking about this in a
variety of different forms we have some
efficient storage mechanism maybe it's
quotes native maybe it's something which
i was gonna answer to your question
about dicing and slicing it so if it is
numbers and you want to say take
everything that's larger than something
the thing is stored as a b tree and so
you really have to scan the whole thing
to get the half that you're interested
about for example
that's
so
but that's but that's in the indices not
not
not in the indices and saying if you
want to take all people were taller than
something and that's something stored as
a number
then you can select them easily
why parliament is that's how it stores
i'm sorry
parliament indices in the database sense
uh steven
the point is that if you want all
transactions with your credit card that
happen between two dates there are ways
of doing that way more efficiently than
going through the whole data set because
it's stored as a tree and so you can get
subparts
that all bets are off when you start
storing and that can work also for
strings for example wait a second
i mean
okay do you have to the question is do
you
if you want to be able to make a query
like that and have it be super efficient
about you know get me the credit card
transactions between these two dates do
you kind of have to tell the database
when you make it or at some prior point
like index by date or something yes yes
yes most definitely
right right which is you can you can't
tell it to index by everything is the
point right you have to take your trade
off you could you you could you're i
mean your database is going to be larger
but you could tell that you want to make
indices across different
costs yeah you can do actually a power
set of all columns not just you know
by two columns of time
right
but again that is okay so that is
content-based
finding of things
okay so what rob is doing right now is a
data container which is all index
gymnastics
rob doesn't care what is stored at each
point he's just going to deliver it to
you based on its indices correct rob
yes i mean i i care what's stored at
each point because that's that's where
the packing will occur is for each each
we'll have packing but besides that i
don't care okay so now the next issue is
in this data structure
are you doing something where you're for
example making a tree of values based on
the payload values
right which you're not doing right now
rob but what people are pointing out is
that
in a database it is typical to index by
some particular dimension on some
particular dimension create some
particular index
which is
a
an efficient way
of storing that content
so that you can ask certain kinds of
questions of the content
correct
yes so typically
that
content storage is what
it's a tree of some kind right
is that right because because it is
something where you're going to have a
linear order as opposed to if it's
strings it's presumably a hash table
is that correct
yeah
and i think postgres has stuff for for
dealing with geo like geo positions and
stuff like that too and
that we're talking about right so at the
bottom level of rob's thing is
fundamentally something that has the
same shape as a single sql table right
so i guess the question is though
as we're talking about right now that's
basically
indexed by
index like it's indexed by the order in
which it appears in the expression is
that right and we're maybe kind of
talking about indexing it by something
else or having some separate index
somewhere else that then you know lets
you basically you specify an ordering of
the other table that lets you make
queries more efficiently or no i think
what rob is saying is
what rob is saying is there is a
the the sequence of in of of list
indices and keys that get you down to a
particular element that's what he's
delivering
is
right which is which is saying that if
you if you ask for the key you know 12
comma
you know
dogs comma weight then that refers to
index 6523
in the table or whatever it is doesn't
matter but he's going to give you he's
going to give you the payload that was
stored at that
index location well i think i think
ultimately i can give you that payload
but but also
you know if you don't if you don't
specify the large you know the column
index it'll give you that entire column
at once
okay fine but be that be that all as it
may there's a different thing which is
find all dogs that weigh more than 300
pounds or something right
and and then look through that table to
find the ones that are relevant and then
i i know but but
in database in the database world it is
typical to take that payload and create
some data structure like a tree for
example based on those values right it
sounds like we can do that because we
can basically index i mean i'm not sure
how the user would request it i mean you
could index again at the bottom of rob's
day structures i understand it you know
you basically just have you know what
looks like an sql database and you could
index it by you know the
sort of the
the index and the expression and the
input expression that might be a
confusing way to put it but you know but
you can also index it by you know the
the weight or the date or whatever you
want
but can i if the point is that in a
national database these things all stand
more or less in equal footing so you
you're also storing the actual you know
index like the social security number as
another column so there is no difference
when you want to slice by social
security number of by weight
it's really the same thing
some are like can't have duplicates i
don't think that yes
we understand but i mean
the point for our purposes is
we have a structure we're starting off
with something which is like our data
set structure
right
it's a hierarchical structure
non-hierarchical it's not quite data set
because data centers can be very
non-rectangular
okay i'm saying a non-ragged data set
it's not about ragness it's about
rectangularness and in a data set you
know you can have a data set where you
have an association where you have you
know
uh the you know the keys people and then
you know the next key is is cars and
under people you have different
parameters and under cars
yeah
okay it's an out of product rectangulary
rectangularly index thing
okay
and but what i'm saying is in the end
it's
unless i'm completely confused there is
a distinction between the payload and
the indices
and what i'm saying is there are
operations like select for example
that operate on the payload not on the
indices
right i'm confused by what you mean by
indices i mean because it's like if you
have a list
right if you have a list of strings of
course the strings in the list are
different from the indices right i mean
12 is an index but
i know i know i know by indices i mean
our kind of indices i'm not talking
about sql indices yeah but what's i mean
why does it have there has to be a
difference between these two things
because we are because we have a way to
understand it that is based on that so
we're going to go with that way of
understanding it if it turns out
implementationally there's no difference
which i do not believe by the way which
i do not believe at all
then so be it but the way we're
understanding it is we have got
something that is
you know structurally like a data set
except that it's an outer product of
indices so it's a restricted kind of
data set
in our data set we have indices and we
have a value we have keys and we have a
value does that make sense
yeah but i mean i guess the question is
though is i mean
maybe i mean the i guess maybe one
question is whether it's possible to
kind of staple on
uh
staple on a uh basically a database that
lets you do these queries more
efficiently because i guess that's why
that's but the point is that the
conceptual point is for our purposes and
i don't care how it's implemented right
now for our purposes we have indices we
have a collection of nested lists and
associations and in the end there is a
value stored do we agree carlo do you
agree
not really but
you don't so why not it's a data set
what's the difference a data set has a
collection of indices and at the end it
stores a value no that's not why i
disagree the reason i disagree is that i
don't think it makes sense to make the
distinction between the indices and the
payload
because the individual but that's not
the same it's made in our language can i
finish my objection or otherwise i can't
go ahead and go ahead so my objection is
that the indices will have the same
properties will have will have to be
uniform in some sense you can't have an
index that's going to be a mix of
positional indexing and
you know string of course if
also have the same columnar structure
what
yes look there's a slot okay each index
the fourth index is always a string
let's say
we're always a real number
we're always an integer no no we don't
have real numbers we don't have real
number indices we don't have what we can
have in an association well why not
i mean because we don't have them
we don't have them we could have them
pronunciations yeah and association
sorry i i think sorry i think you are
confusing indices with keys so indices
are just a few ijk then indices take
values which are keys and then for each
collection of keys we have a payload
what i'm saying is that it doesn't make
any sense to make this distinction
that you can since the ijk have to be
uniform they behave like the payload
okay but i don't agree with you because
i think in our language there is a
distinction right so yes in sql in
relational database theory there isn't a
distinction okay
that has that is a fine and general
theory that applies to two-dimensional
tables basically it's more general than
what you're describing because it can
represent
n dimensional stuff like that
uh i think one way of looking into what
carl is saying is that if you try to
represent this hierarchical structure in
a relational or flat table
then you will end up with some of the
indices being values in that table
okay let's let's it seems like it seems
like maybe just
part of the thing here is i think it's
just for rob's thing to work the sort of
table at the bottom that actually
contains all the values all it needs to
be able to do is take in a number you
know which is sort of the the
number that you get by looking at all
the keys that were that were input and
and then getting out the value
associated with that and so maybe the
point could be
that you can index you know in addition
to sort of indexing by that that number
which is basically the position
then you could also index by other
things like the values and then that
would just let you do better querying in
certain cases
i don't know what the interface with
that would possibly look but look look
look
look
the main point is we're going to have a
function that looks at the final value
and says is the final value and yes you
can do it with relational algebra you
can also do it with the quotes indices
but i'm not considering that case
because in our language for very good
reasons we make a distinction between
the way you access the elements of the
array and the value of that element of
the array
so what i'm asking is we want to do
something where you're selecting by the
value of the elements of the array you
want to find those elements of the array
for which the value is such and such
or is larger than whatever and i'm
asking how do we actually do that and i
assume that the way we do it is to use
all of the stuff we've built
to compile certain kinds of queries to
sql
is that right
or is that we're asking how to do it
better than linear
yeah without scanning everything we're
assuming that it is the case because it
isn't the case
look
generally
i see i think the point that carlo is
trying to make is this
given an index and i mean index in our
sense i'm not interested in the sql
sense here
given an index in our sense
which is okay give given a set of keys
in an association
if those
keys if the thing is a list
it is very straightforward to get the
hundredth element you just go to that
place in the in memory right if the if
it's an association whose keys are
strings you pretty much know you have to
hash that
making sense
yes if the association happened to have
real numbers as its keys
then there is
presumably a tree structure
you know that will get you or
you know in general a kd tree type
structure which is what you'd need for
for geo position things like that you
know there is a tree structure that
would allow you to home in
on the relevant element for you
more efficiently than certainly but by
scanning the things and hashing won't
work for real numbers
is that what you're getting at yeah
and it's it's a little bit better than
that for strings because you can say you
know you want prefixing of strings to be
efficient for example
okay okay but so what you're proposing
here
is something that we do not currently
have which is when you index into an
association
okay and you ask for the such and such
element of an association
right now all we're doing is to do a
hash lookup
of the index
right of the key
that correct yes
okay so what you're saying is in
principle we could have a structure
which we do not have right now
which is the analog of nearest i mean we
have a structure no it is nearest the
structure exists it's called nearest
function
it just isn't packaged like that
right
but what i'm saying is and we could have
a string prefix function
wait wait a second wait a second if all
you're doing is something like nearest
then hashing is the best thing you can
do not
wait wait a second what i'm saying is
that if you want
say two you have a a billion rows and
you want uh to select some that are
within two numbers and and you select a
million of them that can be done faster
than than scanning the whole thing but i
think that's what nearest does though i
mean
this does yeah i mean your nearest
builds a kd tree and it does i think
basically the same thing that a database
does
right
so okay and this is just a detail but
i'm
the main point the main semantics that
we're interested in is being able to do
some kind of select
in
our
sort of multi-dimensional
data container thing a selection on the
values
am i making sense
on the final stored values
now i i guess what you're saying is
um we don't have
how would you do that let's say you have
a series of real numbers
as indices three four and five
in your
array so not in the values in the
indices in the industry it's not
something we do right now it's not this
is not something we do
maybe we're no longer talking about
selecting over the values you're talking
about
well i know but i don't think i don't
know whether it's even useful
it's not so i think
for the sucking over the values case
maybe to take it first because i think
that is for the way we do things right
now that is the more common case i think
i mean
certainly you could do something i mean
if you were just writing in the you know
certainly you can do stuff already where
you where you do something like uh you
know you have your big data structure
and then you put all the weights into a
nearest function
and then tell it okay when i query the
nearest function i want you to give me
back the index in the big data structure
and then you know you can do whatever
query you want to get all the numbers
between x and y and then you know you
get a bunch of indices out and then you
query those
yeah i mean in some cases we already do
like forget about real numbers but in if
you're using temporal data the time
series stuff
you are indexing by date right
so it's not it's not a completely crazy
idea
what is the semantics
right right now
the thing we're doing is
there are a bunch of indices
in our sense
that eventually lead you to a record at
the end that contains several pieces
you know name rank serial number type
multiple pieces
and the things that you are selecting on
are parts of that record
not something at a higher level in the
indices they're parts of that record
that's what you do in
in i think unless i'm unless i'm
confused i mean the case that carl i
mean there's a good case actually carl i
mean like the case of like if you have a
time series when basically you do have
an index that has dates as the type
right so that i mean i think most often
you are doing the case you are talking
about where you're selecting over things
that are in the record but maybe there
are cases also where you're selecting
things that are not in the record but
are in the keys
and it's uh
it's it's really symmetrical like you
can ask for the days where your time
series is larger than something or you
can ask for the wednesdays look
look
in relational algebra there are some
things that are easy and there are some
things that are hard
we're not doing it that way
if we can make use of the things that
that makes easy terrific
but we're not trying to make you know
we've already got a lot of things that
are easy which are hard in that
formulation
so you know and it works well
so we're not breaking what we have right
now for the sake of some theoretical
relational algebra thing
so i mean let's come back to what we
actually need right now
we need something where it is efficient
to go in this out of core
structure
to do some kind of selection on the
out-of-course structure
that's one thing that we need
and the question is how to achieve that
with the framework that rob's built how
do we achieve that presumably we have to
store an index
in the sql sense
at
you know the value level in the
structure
is that right
rob
i i don't know
okay well so yeah
how do we do that
you understand the problem carlo do you
understand the problem
i don't
i'm sorry
carlo did you understand you understand
the problem
i do
okay so what's the answer to that
problem not a different problem about
relational algebra so it depends on what
the payload is in some cases can be done
and the answer is still doing some kind
of tree if the
underlying expression is something
opaque like some kind of you know
compiled struct
oh then obviously it can't be done i
know that i understand that i'm asking
about the case that is the case that
you've already just spent two years
implementing
right i'm asking how do we leverage the
stuff you've already built for sql
databases for this case
well i mean we can
store it somewhere and then access it
quickly i mean
i don't understand what's what do you
want to know about this okay we have i'm
saying we have a data set okay the data
set has a million rows in it each one
has masses of i don't know
i don't know hunks of rock and space or
something right and we want to select we
want to find what is
you know
which hunks of rock weigh more than five
tons
okay which is a query against the
payload
yeah how do we do that efficiently
we've we've now got a mechanism we're
storing
you know rob has provided index
translation
for i don't know what you know some of
those hunks of rock are in earth orbit
some are in mars orbit whatever else i
don't know what those are the top level
indices
now we want to know based on the value
how do we find all hunks of rock larger
than five tons
do you control
creating this database
and writing
let's consider two cases let's consider
because if you control writing to it and
you know that you're going to do the
same thing often
then you can use it no no no no i
understand i understand so you're saying
we can build a structure
out of core
that is optimized for this case
so that's what i listed here you where
did the data come from it's already in
an sql database
right where you may or may not have
indexed on that parameter
right
so if it is an sql database
then there is presumably a query that
you can make
okay you're saying if you are creating
it
well i guess one question i'm asking if
you are creating it what should you
create
within our
framework well
the thing you'll have will be that the
intermediate indices that are used in
this hierarchical construction will
become additional columns in the
database on which we will create an
index so that this search is fast on
them
and the payload will become a column in
that same database as well
and then the
index will be translated into a query
that will extract use those indices to
actually extract the pale the values so
so what you're saying is
if i understand correctly
in
usually in what rob is dealing with
you want to get a particular element and
you do that by indexing down with these
keys to get to that element
you're saying an alternative thing to do
will be to have something which is
essentially content indexed
where
the content value has been turned into
some kind of indexable
yes
thing
and how would we represent that so so
because normally we are going down to
that payload value
how would we represent that yes but
that's uh still that's exactly the same
thing imagine that you have payload
which contains for instance several
fields
could be i know age i get it but look
what you're saying is we can put
essentially a cached index layer
as
an index
in front of and we normally have it's at
this key this key this key this key very
categorical data style
right
you're saying yeah maybe some of that
data is not categorical data it's real
numbers and you can find that you know
certain operations on it you can
okay so so what you're saying is
that you're doing selection with respect
to indices where
what i've been saying is you're doing
you're doing selection with respect to
value you're saying you kind of
pre-compiled
some aspects of the value into something
that looks like an index
and then you're doing operations
not only index but also actual database
column
which
if i understand you're correct let's say
that you have 10 columns of stuff but
one of them
you you know rock size of what steven
said
is something that you want to be able to
search on values
yeah you compile that into 11th column
that if you make a search based on
values
you look up there first and you get what
the row numbers are basically
yeah but
yeah you don't need to do a new column
for that
that's confusingly called an index in
sql
okay
yeah or whatever you call it but you you
make an additional data stream but i
understand but for us
we could imagine that in our data
container
one of the things that rob could be
doing is to store
the an sql style index a a pre
a a sort of uh
you know pre-compiled selection layer
for one of his
let's see how on earth would that work
well actually i mean this this mirrors a
lot what we have been doing in other
areas
we many of the times when we implement
fast operations we have to build a data
structure that gives us fast operations
right
okay
and this is just a more generic sounds
like a more
i don't think it's that generic i think
it's it's actually rather un-generic
because the number of operations that
can be done against for example a
collection of real numbers isn't that
great no i don't think it's exciting
it's various things about you know
greater than maximum whatever else right
which happened to be the things which as
i understand it carlo and friends have
just built the whole mechanism to
compile and sql
am i confused somehow
oh that's right but it can be combined
with other things as i mentioned on a
different meeting uh for certain
specific sql backhands which are in
process such as sqlite or duckdb
they allow callbacks to the kernel
which
may allow you okay i guess
i get it i get it and with the compiler
that becomes more interesting because
you can have a compiled callback
okay but but the basic point is that the
thing that you are describing is
in the data container
you could specify
see the question is the api for the data
container
one
thing that you can do
is just extract elements using quotes
indices our sense of index
see what i'm saying
that's one thing you can do
now we're saying you can also
make a slice
that is not based on our indices
but is based on some aspect of our
values
am i right
yes
yeah okay
all right so now the question is what
does it look like when you do that so
you say data container and the data
container is
you know
in in data set
you would be saying
well i mean you'd be you'd be doing a
select so yeah
steven at least my picture is this
you simply store the intermediate
indices in this hierarchical structure
as extra columns in your sql database if
you if you mean sql way of doing things
and then once you do selection over the
values you extract back both uh the
values and all the basically all those
rows which contain those indices i i
can't allow you to reconstruct back yes
i get it what i'm asking you is
okay
in a data set right now for example what
we have is a series of of levels indices
whatever you want to call them
dimensions
defined by the user or coming from
wherever the data came from okay we
don't we haven't added extra levels we
haven't added an extra quotes sql style
indexing level
right so we could certainly imagine
doing that i want to know what the
semantics we imagine for that are
because for data container there's very
obvious semantics for extracting an
element which will be the same semantics
as for extracting an element of a data
set that is you just give
you know open bracket
index one index comma index two comma
index three and so on right but those
are genuine indices
not these
value-created indices am i making sense
yeah so basically you're asking what to
do if you don't have this structure
ready but instead you just have the data
set hierarchical as is and you want to
know how to do this i want to know what
does it look like in the data container
if there what there will be is certain
operations that you can do on the data
container that are essentially
compilable into whatever the you know
for example into some sql
thing that can be operated against the
the sequence of real numbers that exist
as keys at one level in the hierarchy
right that's a typical type of thing
so what you want to know is like how
would i tell a data set please make the
access to this column fast
it's not a column it's not a column it's
it's just values i mean yes they are in
a column that's what do i make this okay
we have defined essentially a location
a a or a class of locations we've
defined a path effectively
to a certain thing we say all the things
that you access on this path
i want to do operations by value for
things on this path
that makes sense yeah
okay so now how do we set that up
so you are effectively asking about the
generalization of a sparse array with
keys
which can be also strings and whatnot no
no i'm not no i'm not
no
i'm i'm saying i'm saying
there is a way to get there's a path
that gets you down to values which are
masses of rock let's say
okay
that that's a and that and then what i'm
asking is if i want to do a select based
on the mass of the rock
okay i want to have pre-created a tree
that represents all those different
masses of rocks so i can quickly tell
you all the ones more than five tons and
less than seven tons or something am i
making sense
right but it's a it's a thing based on
value it has nothing to do with our kind
of industry so you're saying make this
fast you from now on whenever i ask
about rock masses i want that to be
but the question is what does that look
like in our because we're not creating
one of our style of indices to represent
i mean at least that's not it would be
hidden or something like that right it's
like probably
maybe it shouldn't be hidden i don't
know but the point about it is
we're trying to say but then what is the
x
access
in the data container it would say
something like
it does in a data set which is well
select you know hash
of one comma two comma three comma mass
you know
select those things greater than five
less than seven or something
right so i think that the way one way of
approaching this would have been
to store things internally
uh as a sort of a
flat value list on which you can select
and have some kind of index built on for
them but then have a mapping between
that those flat positions and the
hierarchical positions that are in the
actual data set and that's where i think
rob's work could kind of kick in
yeah
yeah what does it look like what does it
look like when when you're asking
uh you know here in the selection
function you have a data container and
you're asking for
what are you asking for you're asking
for select hash one two three
mass
you know
greater than five let's say
or actually
i mean is that what it looks like
and then the question is how do you
pre-tell it i want queries like that to
be fast
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah so
that would be the equivalent of
what is called create index in sql so
make this access to this column i
understand yeah i understand so you want
to know how
how we tell dc modify yourself so that
this becomes fast right for example yes
or alternatively it could be the case
that we actually want
some form of
you know fake index
that is just this thing fake index in
our sense that is this thing
i don't know
the thing is that if you if you start
considering all of them on equal footing
then select position and then also part
extract etc are all pretty much the same
operation
and so if you optimize one you optimize
all of them
no you don't
no you don't
because the whole point is
to optimize greater than five
right you're not just optimizing
part extraction is just delivering a
value
that requires no back-end computation
any any back end
that we'll ever consider using for
anything can deliver
here's the value from that play defense
it depends not necessarily right i mean
not necessarily but but as a practical
matter everything we've considered can
do that but it is not the case that
everything we've considered can return
you know the arc tangent of the mass
yeah it's greater than five pi or
something so can i make an example
suppose you weigh yourself every day and
you have a data set which is basically
the dates and your weight
so
if you say this is
weights indexed by dates
then
getting the weight you were on yesterday
is a part extraction thing right it's
not average because because dates are a
more complicated thing to to extract
from but they're like why wouldn't you
sometimes you you have data sets that
are indexed by dates for goodness sake
the issue is this there are certain
operations that back ends can natively
deal with
for example finding something that is in
a certain range dealing with basic order
relations and things on the real line
they can deal with that
if i start feeding you more complicated
functions they will not be able to deal
with them
and some back ends will be able to deal
with some functions some will not be
able to deal with those functions
i the question is it could be the case
that things which are essentially range
and interval queries are totally
different from every other query could
be the case i doubt it
so i'm saying that's different from you
know the greater than query is different
from the nearest two query is different
from but these are all queries that are
stories of the real line basically
now
is what you're saying that but our
language does not particularly have
you know have semantics that
distinguishes those kinds of queries
from arbitrary select with all kinds of
criteria queries that have nothing to do
with specifically just orders you know
sort of things about the real line does
that make sense
right so
i think the in real data the point is
that you never ask for like part 47
because you you don't know what it is so
you are always asking for a
something like yesterday
or user 94
right or or you know if you've optimized
right if you've optim if you've added
the tagging you need to optimize
you know the mass greater than five
query
then you know you can ask for you know
the first five of those
very easily
right so right now
you've made position right so if we
create this sort of meta index we've
talked about right that would be
you know mass greater than five comma
three to get the third third one in the
database or whatever
no doubt but the main point that you're
making here is
given something which is in the values
as far as we're concerned
there is the possibility of making that
essentially a faux additional index that
could be used so in other words for data
container normally you go down you say
select this part of this part of this
part of this part right what this is
saying is
there is
a
a different
index path that you could use to get to
those elements
in other words
given okay so so look at the final level
right
at
you know
where is it we have here
you know
at this level
either index
by position
in the level
you know
have a different index
different
indexing scheme
based on some aspect of value
is that right
you know a really nice thing in r and
these things is that you basically treat
that thing that you call math there
which is kind of like a key
right in your case stephen
the mass is a key
yes is to think of that so that's a
column or a generalized column
yeah and
but one thing is to think of that as a
variable
so you could just say mass greater than
five
to
no i don't understand what you're
talking about
but that's precisely what i was talking
about earlier when you isn't that just
the sql indexing by a
by another column isn't it
you convert the index into a column
value
and you store additional indices as just
additional columns in the database
look what i'm saying is
what i'm saying is this the the
okay
let's let's say that we have an array a
okay i'm not disagreeing with what
you're saying stephen i was thinking
this is another
okay i i think okay
you've got an array a
and it has you know it's it's final
let's just do a one-dimensional array we
don't even need to do these higher
dimensional arrays element three four
five of the of that array
okay
we can we can extract that element the
element is 67 let's say okay
an alternative thing that we might want
to do
is to
say
we have created some kind of index of
the values here
and what we want to do here is select
you know hash greater than five or
something
okay
this being based on the and we we have
certain operations but this this being
based on the index
of values
do you get what i'm saying here
yeah it's an alternative indexing scheme
for a
based on the values
now
my question is
it's probably the case
how to think about this
i mean
i mean one way to think about that is a
mask
for that column
for that value
i'm saying yeah like all all the
the indexes in our meaning
it's just like this is like we would say
yeah exactly 14 or something right
yeah that or you could say a open
bracket
hash mass greater than five but that's
just
steal the part like a span
well but it isn't hash mass would be
look hash is the main is the value is
the payload let's say look okay so let's
say uh let's say we said something like
this
um
you know value index defunct
which is
maybe more than you need to say but
let's imagine we did that let's imagine
we had a thing that said that now
clearly
if we had multiple
isn't that a variant of position
like you're you want the position by
predicate right yes but yes but the
whole point is you can't do for example
value indexed
a func on on two
indices you can only do it on one index
ever why because it won't because it
doesn't mean anything in this case this
is you're picking up this is saying
okay
this case is perfectly meaningful you go
down here you select only that sub slice
within that sub slice you value index
i'm asking like you could you could in
principle to say i want to know who are
the people who are taller than something
and heavier than something
nope nope nope nope you never need more
than one of them you never need more
than one because this function
by the time it's looking at the value
those different elements height and
weight and so on those are parts of the
value
they're parts of the value right
remember in our setup you've got the
array a it has a bunch of indices in our
sense and then it has a value
that value could itself be
a
be something that has you know be an
association for example
right am i making sense
but it's a it's a separate value it's
not something where
i mean
maybe maybe you're making a different
point i think the point you're making is
not right but the point
it is the case that you obviously might
want to select so so here see remember
these are not different hierarchical
levels these are within one level you
see what i'm saying
yeah but i'm i'm just saying that if you
consider the sparse version of that
then you don't care about the levels
we're talking about the levels data
container is for rectangularized arrays
that are not sparse that's what we're
talking about here if we talk about
sparse arrays we're in a different we're
in a different area that's a different
thing we're talking about
rectangularized arrays what i'm trying
to say is that sparse 2d things and by
2d the second d is that you can have
both height and weight and then phone
numbers that's not the same dimension
it's not the same it's not the same no
no it's the same meaning let me finish
what i'll say is that if you index
sparsely into association without
talking about sparse index okay let's
not talk about what we're talking about
that's not what we were talking about
this whole meeting is about dense
rectangularized arrays am i correct
we're not talking about the sparse case
i don't think he's saying the data is
sparse i i think
you're creating a sparse slice
am i correct carlo no what am i mean
what i'm saying is that
you you have
you're you're making the distinction in
order to get to this thing the way you
are thinking about it you're making a
distinction that is quite artificial
and that you can store arbitrarily deep
in the sense of indices things by just
thinking about them as 2d sparse things
that they are equivalent algebraically
you didn't just need to drop the
distinction between values and indices
but we don't drop that distinction our
language is based on indices values okay
we could have designed it differently
but we didn't and
so that's what we're going from we're
not changing that we're trying to
understand how do we make use of what we
can make use of from these other ideas
we're not saying we're changing that so
nobody understands anything
right
it's the transducers even you don't have
to change anything exactly that's the
whole point of designing this thing like
you then people will use selected they
will lose position they will use things
that are familiar to them but it doesn't
need to be like that all the way down
that's all i'm saying so okay does
anybody else understand this yes okay
let me explain how i see this steven
we are uh designing this uh rather
opaque uh structure which is this uh
scaffolded array so we allow certain
translation layer in between isn't that
the whole business yes that is the whole
point so so that is exactly the layer
that is supposed to be a translation
layer between how it looks from the
outside which is hierarchical in this
indices and how it may be stored inside
which for instance can be a flat table
with those indices becoming new just as
right whatever that's fine what i'm
saying is what is the semantics what
what what does it look like what we
would be doing here
okay we need some way of saying i want
these particular elements of this array
we have that in dataset
yeah i mean you can just put all comma
all come on all up to the last layer
which is the bottom one where the values
sit yes but you can't do this you can't
do this this is the point i was making
you can't do this you can't expect that
to work there is only one place you can
index by value
so it's like position it's like position
yeah
you know select gives you the actual
values right but position gives you the
actual sort of indices
i understand but but what this is doing
is it's saying one of the one of the
indices here is going to be based on the
value not based on the part yeah yeah
yeah yeah only one you
and i think it's just wrong
okay because what's happening is
i'm i'm trying to understand this can
only be
a path
because i i don't know i'm not sure what
you mean by the value right because if
we have height and we have weight
what what is the value that we're
getting into is that like
my name like what is what is the value
maybe we're not agreeing on what the
example actually is which is why we're
disagreeing about
well it's this thing here okay so so we
have a whole list of height and weight
values right okay
so right so so if so right so you're
saying we have two values so why can't
we
index on two values give me all entries
which have
height greater than five and weight
greater than okay what's the center
what's the syntax for that those are not
two different levels they're at the same
level
that was at the same level because the
thing right
so if you what if you really had
right uh
um right a bunch of associations like
this right you could you would do pounds
pound height greater than whatever and
pound weight greater than yes
yes
that's what i'm saying
but suppose you wanted to do it by body
mass index you'd have to combine height
and weight
yes right so that's what you're doing in
this value index thing yeah that's
exactly what you're doing the thing that
i'm saying is
i mean still why
why do we even consider an index as a
kind of headdresser why can't we add it
as a part of this data set as as a
metadata we you then can have as many
indices as you want
because you can't
this value the values are at the end
you see what i'm saying the values are
at the end you go index index index
index index value
this is something being computed on the
values
yes right but then the question is what
as as as previously roger was saying or
it i was saying
what uh what we consider value in some
cases the value can happen you are
getting confused because you were
considering this case
where
where you could have an intermediate
index
that is something that has operations
doable on it
other than just matching it
that's the case you're considering which
is a case we have not otherwise
considered
exceptionally nervous
okay let's maybe i'm misunderstanding i
don't understand why value index if if
value index is like position
why doesn't it give you the full set of
uh like
if i ask you like who are
the things that the leaves of this big
tensor that have height and weight
larger than something why is this not
returning the whole sequence of the
position
why just one index it's returning all of
that
yes it returns all of them always all of
them so you don't do like five to one
and then value indexed really
yeah maybe this is the confusion
why why do you want to specify the five
to one
before because because it's saying
within that sub-slice
i want the things where this is greater
than seven or something so what i'm
saying within that sub-slice yeah but
wouldn't wouldn't that like this
you want to separate that sub slice in
the higher indices from the sub slice
and lower indices they don't need to be
the same function
no no no that's not what i'm saying
no
like imagine you have a first index
that's like department and it's a string
and then you have a second linux that's
just you know the third person in that
thing
so
in in general
if you want to say just give me the
people in the ece group and their weight
and height
why wouldn't you also put that in the
select really
and say
you know select people
i think this is what steven means so i
think that the pre-index the 521 you
could think of them as
um spans for instance you know and the
only thing that that does is select a
subarray
yes that's right okay so it should have
said that was a span there could have
been an all there right
okay so that's a span so now we're
looking at sort of the last thing which
is our generalized column
now find me everything in that last
piece you know in that generalized
columns basically columns
um that satisfy the condition
let's make this i i mean i want to see
this let's say that this is like the
first thing is like we're talking about
an army and the first thing is like army
and the second one is uh
navy and then air force the first index
tells you which part of the uh you know
the generalized army this is and then
you have corpse or whatnot and then you
have
platoons and i'm trying to think of a
hierarchy of people there
i think that steven is just setting this
up for something more general question
database in the metrics and then you
still want to be used be able to use the
matrix indexes too yeah but what i'm
saying is that these things like if you
if you make if you have them effectively
a matrix of you know
platoons and
armies and corpse and whatnot
why
when you're asking this stuff wouldn't
you put it all in the same place
as a big select statement
instead of making this gymnastics here
mixing in oh i see that's a syntax thing
yeah
wow but that's just like a
thought process thing like why why would
you want to think in the time of life
five to one and then
ask for what you want and not just ask
for what you want yeah i know i agree
that's what i said at the beginning
but by by the way i mean this is this is
closely related to some of the syntax
like query and data sets indeed like
where you can put a select in the middle
of it
indeed
this is a yet different case that carlo
has been implicitly talking about which
is the case where
a
the indices the keys of an association
are something like real numbers
and what we have done
in selecting pieces of an association
the most obvious way to do it is
directly by
i mean we don't have we're not it's not
very common we could do it you could do
it you know we don't do a nearest key
of another
maybe associations aren't really the
right thing for that though maybe there
should be a different
uh
you know
because because the point of
associations is they're like hash maps
right and they're like hash tables yeah
so i think that that this is something
where i mean well arguably mental models
it's fundamental models that lists are
like arrays associations are like hash
tables and maybe it makes sense to have
some other thing which would be useful
for for dates certainly and maybe other
real value things that's that's like a
you know
some sort of binary tree or something or
katy tree
or or more more like it i'm just
thinking of like let's
transpose this thing around and say that
this thing is a list
of associations that contain height
weight and then first index
index no you're getting confused again
the point that christopher is making
which is one of about six points that
you seem to make in carlo
is that there is a different case that
we do not currently have which is a a
structure that is
a
you know
a
real number maps to value i mean we have
that in interpolating function we have
it in a bunch of different places but we
don't have and we have it in nearest
function and so on it is somewhat
related to
what we have the notion of lists and
associations but it is neither a list
nor an association it's something
slightly different
now we have a bunch of operations for
dealing with but we don't have kind of a
single native type and it could be that
our sort of um
uh
uh you know interfacing to databases
is
you know precisely
the thing that that makes
you know you understand what i'm saying
that that's convenient when you're
interfacing to databases to have such an
object
we need to wrap up for today um i'm a
little frustrated that i feel like we're
you know
this particular issue
of
you know these things operations within
a data container selection operations we
haven't even talked about aggregation
operations
um
how we specify those
and then how different back ends work
with those because i think we we did
talk a bit about how
the pure
select an element based on indices of
our kind
right we explained how that might work
for things that are backed by files
databases whatever else
what we're now talking about is how
things that
select
elements
by value might work
and then we need to talk about how
things that aggregate values might work
am i making sense
yeah well i think what we really need is
you know a few
more concrete examples like actual i
mean even right not actual complete data
sets but sort of little pictures of
here here's my here here's what my keys
look like
and here are the operations i want and
here's what i want but
i think we've stayed too abstract
yeah well and we're not all agreeing on
what we mean as a result
yeah well fine so let's get that for
next time but then then what we want
you know the purpose of this
was to talk about
you know
what's a con again we have to be very
clear on this where did the data come
from
right and which of these
options here are things where you
realistically got it from somewhere else
making sense
yeah
another thing i would add for next time
and i will do the homework on my part i
think it's very useful to have examples
of what you have in mind just to dispel
the
and yeah but also examples of how we
think
we can use it like uh how how you like
the machine learning pipeline is going
to use this this is
is putting some not only constraints on
the design but but the
pointers that that might help making the
discussion more concrete
right
sounds good all right let's wrap it up i
i mean if we're able to do one of these
soon i don't know whether everybody's
dissipating
dispersing
um
but if we're able to do another one of
these before the end of the year it'd be
nice
uh
i don't know we'll have to see because i
feel like the longer we leave it the
more confused we're going to be the next
time we start up
but i think we've got a definite path
that involves finding some examples et
cetera and it's great to hear that rob
is on his way to implementing
the thing we've you know the the the non
and rob does it make sense to you you're
implementing things other than these
things is that correct
right yeah no i mean i'm i mean i've got
a i mean i'm implementing a prototype of
an idea which
which you know i'll call data container
and
you know it'll have a certain
certain api and then then
we'll have to see
if it's flexible enough to work for
these other cases
right right
right
it will be neat it will need these cases
but right now all it is is it is
extracting slices
elements or slices of elements purely by
index in our sense of index
yes precisely so that's that's that's
what i mean
so so don't be disappointed if it
doesn't have anything more than that no
that that's already very useful to be
able to do that and and it will reduce
the storage needs by some huge factor
yes and then we have to understand for
what you want there
which is already very useful how can we
back that with things other than in core
stuff
right precisely
aggregation at the column level
because of the way things are
represented is usually
clean
right but it may be that there are some
pre-aggregates that we can store which
is sort of the promise
which i don't think is realized in olap
and is the thing that we've thought
about multiple times over the last
decade that we've thought about you know
how do we store data so that a bunch of
it is pre-aggregated so that you know i
think i think
someone had used the example you don't
want to ever get this weird slice of the
data you want to get slices that are
easy to describe so this is a
pre-aggregation just like we've
described elsewhere a pre-indexing a
pre-trifocation
this is another kind of trification-like
operation that is a sort of cache
summarization of asp of slices of the
data that you are likely to ask for
did that make sense
yeah i mean it's very similar in spirit
to things like the pre-fetching of
entity slices and so on this is all the
same type of thing of what are you
likely to ask for together
you know
and and sometimes with some kinds of
data it's very hard to know that
and other cases it's rather obvious what
you know you'll want to ask for the
average weather in a month
not the average
weather in a very bizarrely aligned
month so to speak
make sense
[Music]
okay
good stuff
all right
thanks guys and uh see you later thanks
to folks on the live stream as well
oh somebody was asking okay one question
here somebody was asking why are we not
using s
h s q l d b
i don't know what that is
sh no h sqld
hs2ldb
it's a memory database which
has a rather
limited
uh scope
of applicability but it probably should
be on our list here
actually yeah and we actually bundle
that with
database link right i mean it's a pure
java yes file based database right and i
think we actually bundle the
bundle that with database link
yeah i will add it to the list as well
as hdf
sounds good all right see you guys see
you guys later
bye for